Kepentingan quantum computing ni sebenarnya terlalu direndahkan
dan pada masa yang sama terlalu dilebih-lebihkan.
Walaupun ia tak akan gantikan komputer konvensional,
inovasi kuantum mewakili paradigma pengkomputeran yang baru.
Komputer kuantum boleh bekerjasama dengan infrastruktur pengkomputeran
semasa untuk selesaikan masalah kompleks yang sebelum ini
dianggap tak praktikal atau mustahil.
Ini boleh jadi pengubah paradigma.
Contohnya, kesukaran untuk faktorkan nombor besar
kepada nombor perdana mereka adalah asas kepada
kriptografi moden. Untuk saiz nombor yang digunakan dalam kunci awam
peribadi moden, pengiraan ini akan ambil
komputer konvensional paling laju lebih 300 trilion tahun.
Untuk komputer kuantum berskala besar yang bekerja
dengan algoritma Shor, pengiraan ini boleh ambil masa beberapa saat je.
Masalah kompleks macam ni wujud merentasi semua industri.
Potensi aplikasi untuk quantum computing
memang sangat luas.
Komputer kuantum dah pun semakin besar
dan lebih berkebolehan,
memandangkan kami cuba atasi masalah yang lebih rumit.
Sejak 2016, IBM dah buat komputer kuantum boleh diakses
oleh orang ramai melalui laman web dengan antara muka grafik yang
nampak macam skor muzik.
dan kit pembangunan perisian Qiskit
yang benarkan pengguna aturcara komputer kuantum.
Saintis di dalam dan luar dunia korporat
sedang jalankan eksperimen
melalui portal yang serupa. Mereka terokai pendekatan dalam kimia
dan masalah pembelajaran mesin, cuba cari tahu
soalan macam mana yang boleh mereka tanya
dan macam mana mereka akan bingkai soalan-soalan tu
bila teknologi dah lebih maju nanti. Inilah masa yang
sesuai untuk pemimpin perniagaan bersedia
untuk quantum. Keadaan dah ada untuk bereksperimen
dan kembangkan teknologi baru yang asasi ni.
Organisasi yang ingin berada di
barisan hadapan peralihan transformasional ini akan
rebut kelebihan bersaing. Latihan ini
akan sediakan kamu untuk mulakan perjalanan quantum kamu!